es un balance positivo del cual es
reflejo lo que está ocurriendo ahora
mismo en la plaza de bolívar aquí en el
centro de bogotá este escenario es un
escenario que hemos visto pocas veces
durante los últimos días de protestas
aquí en bogotá ha sido muy difícil ver
una congregación de personas tan grandes
que lleguen a esta hora cuando ya
comienza a entrar la noche en bogotá sin
que haya ningún tipo de enfrentamiento o
choque la presencia de la publicidad es
prácticamente nula al igual que la del
escuadrón antidisturbios la tónica es la
misma que hemos visto desde que
comenzamos a hacer este cubrimiento en
horas de la mañana una marcha masiva
pacífica en este caso quienes están aquí
en su mayoría en la plaza de bolívar son
sobre todo jóvenes que como mayor
incidente protagonizar una toma de la
estatua de simón bolívar que da nombre a
esta plaza siendo eso el mayor incidente
de lo que ha sido esta jornada masiva y
pacífica
-juan sin embargo algunos puntos de la
capital colombiana están registrando
problemas en la movilidad problemas para
desplazarse
largo y ancho de la ciudad y también hay
preocupación porque la capacidad de las
unidades de cuidado intensivo allí por
el cob y 19 están llegando ya al límite
pero a esta hora sobre todo cuando
aquellas personas que no han participado
de este paro y que han tenido una
jornada laboral vuelven a regresar a sus
hogares en una ciudad con más de 7
millones de personas hay problemas de
movilidad aquí en el centro también en
el norte donde hay otra protesta también
de estudiantes algunos de ellos también
protestando de manera masiva siendo eso
los mayores son muy grandes altercados
los dos mayores puntos de concentración
que están obstaculizando el tráfico en
lo que se refiere al transmilenio que es
el sistema de transporte masivo de
bogotá hasta esta hora opera solamente
en uno de esos tramos la alcaldesa de
bogotá claudia lópez pidió que fuera
ésta una jornada pacífica y así la clara
ella misma calificó que era una jornada
pacífica y una de sus peticiones era de
que esta marcha fuera terminando cuando
entrara la noche como está ocurriendo
ahora días antes y ella claudia lópez
había hecho un pedido de auxilio para la
población de bogotá teniendo en cuenta
que se ha llegado al 96% de la ocupación
de las camas de cuidados